if Judy Dench told you to do something
you'd do it wouldn't you yes yes so I
got a letter and this this man was very
very certain that whoever I was with was
I was not meant to be with and he was
the man for me and Judy said oh Rossi
she said you have to go for dinner with
him I said do I said well we don't know
anything about him who she said well
let's look him up on the internet
it's all my whole future anyway so I did
go for dinner with him yes because Judy
tells you to go for dinner with someone
you go and how was the dinner it was
lovely I mean we're not we went together
for very long that's very brave and
amazing he did begin the conversation
actually by saying you probably I said
we looked you up on the Internet me and
Judy he said you probably got the story
about the body washed up and I'm not
joking he said you probably got the
story about the body washed up at my
house by the beach I said um no